good morning thanks very much uh for
attending P dat that we got the first
session in this room uh the first
Speaker uh we have a data science lead
from meta uh traveling from uh just from
Paris yesterday uh so we're going to
talk about uh lifetime value and
forecasting through p stand so if you
would like to all give Rafael Tamaki a
big
[Applause]
clap thank you aded thank you everyone
to decide that decide today that to have
this presentation as your first one for
this whole conference I hope you will
like it but I will uh say that I'm going
to teally probably most of the budget
for number of slides so I'm going to be
quite fast here I think I just have made
one over 100 so prepare yourself I hope
you took a good amount of coffee so
let's start off so
just a little bit short about myself so
I'm a data science lead in the market
science department meta where I apply
cause inflence techniques to help
advertisers increase the effectiveness
of their marketing Investments I'm also
a montainer of geolift which is an open
source technique for measuring Market
Effectiveness using Geographic qu
experiments prior to that I work as a
staff data science at Wildlife Studio
which is a mobile game developer and
publisher
there I was a tech lead for the lifetime
value team where I develop lifetime
value model for launch of five different
games and I additionally also
implemented ad monetization agreements
that help increase that revenue of the
games in the
company this presentation is going to be
divided in two parts first I'll give you
a short introduction about advertising
for digital products and the reason and
motivation behind why we should use
appropriate list modeling when we are
estimating
LTV hopefully that will be clear by
after some 8 minutes and then I will
show you how you can use p stand to
forecast L TV I will describe a little
bit about the data set that I'm going to
use for this example describe the
mathematical model and show how you can
Implement that both in p stand which the
title of this presentation but also in
PC I will finish up by comparing these
two libraries in terms of of computation
performance so that you have at least
some idea of in which situation you
should use either one of
them so let's start off with uh modeling
advertisement for digital
products let's suppose that you have a
mobile game and this mobile game you
have the possibility to find it like in
Apple or Google Play
Store in startall it and enjoy it after
a little bit so what would happen is
that people would find your game
naturally install it and this tle
repeats every day some some days are
going to get more users some get less
user but every day are going to get some
users that find your app naturally that
find your app organically just by
looking at the App
Store however that is just a small
portion of all the people that could
actually find your game that could
actually download it and
enjoyed and that's one of the main
reasons why companies use these digital
platforms such as Twitter Google Tik Tok
Facebook among L they probably should
not be using Twitter right now
right let's take an example and select
let's say Twitter after you slack one of
these digital platforms you can be even
more specific about the type of people
that want to reach out you can Define as
charactertics about the people that are
going to see the ad of your game let's
say you can Define women you may Define
that they have future as a plus maybe
only those that use iPhone or live in
the
Netherlands whatever you decide to
choose this combination of digital
platform and T and additional
characteristics is going to define the
target population the audience that can
see your ad is not going to be that all
of them are going to but it's going to
be all that could
after you do that what is going to
happen is that you're going to start
investing money in this digital platform
to show add to these people and so that
some of these people will find it
interesting download it enjoy it and
hopefully for your company that they
spend some money on it and Cy is going
to be repeated every day so some days
you're going to be invest more money and
as a consequence going to get more users
and some days they are going to invest
less money against some less
users and if you were to have a closer
look of what is actually happening there
we see that depending on the target
population that is selected for example
this green line here it could happen
that you have a lot of user installing
your game just by using a small bit but
that quickly saturates at a lower
point but if you decide to use a
different target audience or let's say
even optimization you would have that
you would have very low downloads at the
very beginning with a little bit but
that number of downloads will increase
as you increase the bid much more
rapidly and you have a much higher
number of downloads as a
consequence so depending on the Target
aers and your bid you may have very
different number of doons that from your
marketing campaign so this cycle can be
uh described in this diagram here which
has three steps the first step is where
you
define the number what is the number of
dolls that you're going to get and as I
just described it depends on the target
a that you selected and the bid that
you're using to operate your Market
campaign so and this is process is what
I'm going to call here for the rest of
the uh this presentation as the volume
function how does the bid affect the
number of downloads next you have to
transform downloads into revenue and to
that is what I'm going to call here the
lifetime value so how much revenue each
does each one of these users generate on
average and lastly we have the profit
which is just the difference between
revenue and cost and when you're
operating a market company what you want
to do is find a bit that your the
highest profit so how can you find it
well let's take a closer look again at
the profit equation here if you were to
expand this two this two the revenue and
cost what we would see is that revenue
is just the multiplication of downloads
and LTV and similarly cost is the
multiplication of downloads and the bid
how much you pay to get each one of
these on
average this can be further simplified
and then I can substitute downloads by
the volume function that I described
before so that we have an equation that
depend on LTV bid and this volume
function the L TV at least in this
presentation at least at some under some
constraints you can assume that it can
be constant when you are making the bid
itself so that when you define the
Target on and for the duration of your
compaign your LTV is not going to be
depending on the bid or going to change
dramatically from one point of the other
and similarly the volume function again
defines the is defined by the Target
population that you said at the very
beginning so for example in this case we
could have select Twitter women of 50
years plus of age iPhone Netherlands and
with that def is probably not going to
be changing dramatically over the
duration of your campaign so much that
your profit equation can be simply fied
as a as a function of the
bid and if you were to experiment with
very many different
bits higher lower what you would get as
a consequence is a function a curve that
look like this orange one here and this
function have mainly two properties one
if you bat zero you are not going to get
any download from this platform and the
consent not going get any Revenue
back and also if you B exactly how much
is users are worth well it doesn't
matter how much dollars you get you also
get no profit out of it and in between
these two points you're going to have
profit and in one specific point you're
going to have the highest profit
possible and the highest profit possible
is actually a little bit easier to find
if you know the TV and as I said it's
not not going to change dramatically at
least on each Bid And also the volume
function is not going to change because
you already defined the target ons for
your marketing so much that if you know
how this volume function Works ATS or
LTV you can find the optimal bidding
Point by just putting any Optimizer that
well basically exist in any programming
language and it's going to give you back
the bid that generat the highest profit
for your marketing
campaign however I just said that you
know your LTV right well actually don't
know your LTV that's one thing that we
estimate it's not something that is know
from let's say out of the bat and if he
the estimate well you are not going to
be sure about you you can be wrong you
can be overestimated underestimated so
what is the role that this uncertainty
play in your marketing
strategy let's go back to the equation
again and see what exactly happens when
you don't know your L TV when you don't
know LTV well it basically means that
your LTV can be under or overestimated
and if it's underestimated what is going
to happen that you're going to think
that your users are worth less than they
actually are and the consequent going to
be beating less than you actually should
and it's going to generate a lower
profitability point for your Market
campaign and similarly if you
overestimate your LTV what's going to
happen as a consequence that you are
also going to beat higher and Escape
more much more than you should and also
not going to have as many Revenue as
many profit as you actually
should this can be especially specially
especially dangerous depend on how much
you overestimate if you overestimate a
lot it's going to happen that your
profit that you think your marketing is
generating is very high but the actual
profit can be very low even negative so
that you can take a long time think that
your markeet is generate like a lot of
money but actually are just burning
money out of it so this can be a
especially dangerous
situation and if you were to have a
closer look at what's going to happen
depending on the Arrow level that have
underestimating or overestimation you're
going to see this this line here where
it's more a little bit more clear what
that depending on how asymmetric this
profit curve is and again this are
usually a consequence of this volume
function how many dollars you get by how
much you bid you may have to underbid on
your Maring campaigns and as well how
much you under be depend on how
concerned you are about your LTV so much
that when you are really really
uncertain about the LTV how much you
should be actually beating you have to
be even more
careful about how how you
beat so depending on these two uh
characters the volume function and the
and insert you have to build differently
on your market cign so for example you
may have to be a fraction of actually
the expect TV that to generate you're
predicting so how can you find your LTV
how can you find your distribution the
possible values that your marketing
compaign can
have well you can use pan that's
probably why you are all here right so
what is pyan well you probably already
know but python is actually just a
python interface to Stan and Stan itself
is a platform for statistical modeling
that allow for high performance statical
competition it was released in 2012 and
since then has been qu used in the
different scientific
Fields partially because of the
interface to both R and python but
mainly because of the implementation of
efficient sampling algorith so we are
going again to touch what we just had on
the talked before on PC on Mark out
chance but I'm not actually going to
describe anything that's going on
there so for this example I'm going to
use this lifetime value data set that is
available from cgo so you can probably
use the same data that I'm going to this
data set was shared three years ago by
David hodri and it contains anonymized
data about users that subscribe to a
product in a
website when they subscrib to this
product they had to pay a fee that is
renewed let's say every month every week
to have access to this product this data
set contains around 900,000 users data
that's is over 212
days so if we were to have a look at how
this data set is you would
see uh this head up here so you would be
able to see that we have many different
characteristics about our users we have
when the user joined the credit card
level which product they adopt and even
the country they come from however for
simplification I'm just going to focus
on two of them the joint date and the
target the LTV so much that if you were
to plot this two so that the join date
is on the xaxis and the target L is the
y axis what we'll see is this blue line
here well look a little bit more black
right in which we see in deep the blue
or black the average value and in this
light blue region the 95% confidence
interval and what we are going to do
here is use some training data to
forecast LV in the future let's say five
days
ahead so what is the model that we are
going to do for that well let's go back
to the process that I just described at
the beginning of the
presentation in that if you were to have
a closer look at what is actually
happening there and remember what I said
before what we have is that every day we
have this target population and we get
just a small sample out of it we just
get a small portion of all the people
that we are targeting that we could
actually have install our game and this
cycle repeats every day so that every
day we show some ads and get a small
share a small sample of these
people however even though it's always
the same people we are always Target the
same
population doesn't actually mean that
the TV can be the same from one day to
the next right the TV can change maybe
because of different way days of the
week maybe it's weekend maybe they want
to spend more maybe it's is a different
day for the month maybe they got just
their paycheck maybe there is global
economic change maybe there just
occurred a pandemic over in the world so
even though we have always the same
people being Target the LTV may change
from one day to the next and one of the
most simplest assumption that we can
make is that the LTV can be uh described
as a random walk so that we expect the L
from one day to be the same L at the
previous day but folling a normal
distribution and similarly the L that we
have on each one of our users is
actually just a sampling process so that
in this case I decide to use a normal
distribution could use all distributions
as well that have the expected value DTV
of the population at the date that is
user joined but also we have a normal uh
distribution here standard deviation
sampling so that our model can be
describing by these three equation first
is how we describe the Del TV follows a
random walk Del TV of our population
follows a random walk next we have the
definition that the LTV of each one of
our user the LTV that we actually
observe
follows also normal distribution and it
is a sampling process and the Del TV and
then we have to define the prior for our
parameters in this case it's I'm just
going to show one but uh which is Dela
of the population at the initial
date so how would we Implement that
model in p stand well this is a very
short simplification but first you have
to Define and call stand and then you
have just two here one is the build
where you're actually going to compile
the model and then the posterior
distribution where you're going to get
the sample for your
parameters let's just focus into the
second line here we have this time
series model which is a string that is
actually exactly the stand model that is
going to happen in the back end and the
stand data which is actually a
dictionary stand at least pice that
doesn't actually receive a a data frames
that you would normally be using for
something as
color it use the dictionary and in this
this dictionary we are going to pass
four arguments first is the number of
data points that we have for our data
set the number of users that we have
then we have to define the number of
dates in our training data then the
dates that each one of our user joined
and observation is the LTV of each one
of our users in the training data
with that clear let's take a closer look
of what is actually happening in the
time series model what is the actually
model getting passing to The
Stand St models always have at least
three
blocks it has the data block which is
where we
Define the kind of data that's going to
be passed to the
model then we have the parameters where
we declare the varibles that we want to
estimate and lastly we have the model
block where we connect the parameters
with the
data have let's have a Clos look what is
happening the data block again remember
that we just passed a dictionary again
the number of data points and is an
integer the number of dates also an
integer refer to the number of different
dates that we have on our training data
then we have the usual level information
when each one of our users joined which
is a vector with the with n values and
observation which going to hold the LTV
of each one of our users and it's also
going to be a vector with and different
values then we can just see what is
going to actually happen with for mod
how we can actually Implement these
equations in p stand first we have to
Define delative of our population which
is going to also be a vector with the
with a number of values equal to the Nal
dates in our training data
then we have to define the standard
deviations for our model which both are
going to be real numbers real posit
number at that and then we can Define
finally the model
itself in basically any of the
probability model that you're going to
do both in PC or P you are almost always
going to start by declining the prior
for your parameters in this case I
decide to call the prior for my
parameters the standard deviation are
half CI
distribution and for uh the first value
of my LTV of the population at a number
distribution we expect the value six and
divion three then we can Define that Del
of our population follows around the
walk and that is done by saying that LTV
of our users is expected to be the same
value at the previous point but
following a norm
distribution and similarly
the LV of each one of our users also
follows a normal
distribution where we expect LV to be LV
of the population when these users
joined and the standard deviation that
is the sampling stdv
here as much that if you were to use the
training data that I show you at the
beginning that time series model time
series data and this model that I just
described we're going to get this line
here where we see that the expect LTV of
our data the LTV population is in
blue and you may think that is not going
to be fitting well but actually we are
not feing the LTV that we observe on
each one of the DAT the user level LTV
but actually what we expect LTV of our
population to be at that point so you'll
see that it's not going to be following
the the noise that we have on the LTV of
each given date so much that after we
have that after we estimate our data we
can use the parameters to
say forecast TV in 5 days in the future
and we can do that and if think that
delv of our users let's say is six and
even find the credible interval from 5%
to
95% and we can repeat this process for
every day in our training data so that
every day we add an additional date to
our training data and forecast five in
the future if we repeat this process
again and again what we would see is
this gr green line here where you see
that the expected value is in deep uh
deep green and the 95 credible interval
and it shows that where we expect the LV
of our population to be in any given
point in the
future so I just show how we can
Implement that model in Pyon but what do
we look in PC well I'm going to go
actually very fast here but similar to
that you would call PMC and just find
the model and we start
by calling the prior for our parameters
again I'm using the same prior that
before standard uh normal distribut for
my expected value of the LTV population
and a half Ki for both standard
deviations then we have to define the
that the LTV of population follows walk
and the LTV of our users is also from a
sampling process with a normal
distribution how would these two models
compare in term of performance only
performance well it's not going to be a
perfect bench mark this is only going to
compare this model and this data set so
if you try out again you may see
something different but using this data
set and using different number of users
by doing a sampling process with
replacement so that I have 10,000 20,000
50,000 and 100,000 what I saw is that P
C Al to performs P stands after 20,000
data points before that p stand is
perform a little bit better than Pi uh
PMC so much that you can see here that
again around 20,000 10,000 20,000
they're both very similar but after
50100 pyan is clearly taking much longer
then primc to generates the
distributions of our
parameters however this is only using
the default Samplers that you will be
using IF for Neal PMC and p stand if you
were actually using some non default
Samplers actually they actually just
released it a little bit better now but
there's two non default samples not pi
and N this do use a different back end
than the default sampler and if you do
that if you use not p you see a huge
liap in terms of performance you see
that if we use n and n par you are going
to take much much less time than when
you using the default
sampler one point worth of attention
though is that
PC because it's actually a much more
maintaine Library actually allow you for
multiple implementations of the same
model for example using different class
and some classes can place significantly
lower performance so what I show that
before is the implementation above where
I'm only using statistical distributions
to implement my random walk if I use the
gon random walk that PC provides out of
the B and at least that was my first
implementation you take significantly
longer if you use the G the walk you see
almost it taking three times longer than
one you use in the implementation that I
showed just before so it's what you can
face if you're new is is that your model
will maybe take longer because you are
May using a class that is not optimized
for what you're trying to
do another thing that I would like to
say is
that what I test just before is when I
keep the number of my model the same
increase the number of data points
another Benchmark done by josua cook in
the I think is from the US is when we
keep the nerval data points the same the
model is the same but increase the
number of groups the number of different
let's say combination of
coari and cardinality of your coari self
so that you may have let's say 10
different groups 20 different groups 100
different
groups this was this B model was
actually doing stand and pacy 3 which is
the older version but you can see that
it's going to be a little bit consistent
with what I just called when your models
are more complex p is going to take less
time than St to to do to find your
parameters so one would be my summary
here is
that I would recommend people to use PC
if for data large if for modular complex
you have many uh cover High cality
hierarchical models if there's a ready
to use implementation available for
example PC already provides you
marketing mix
models uh conver uh lifetime value
models or if you can use the IND devel
Samplers n par P that are much faster
than the default one and I recommend to
use Pyon if your data is too
large your M AR too complex or you or
your colleagues have experienced work
with stand for another programing li
like are I so in conclusion depending on
the property of our marketing caign the
uncertainty of our estimat May hugely
impact the strategy and how you best
operate them we saw how we can implement
the P DTV in PC or stand that PC perform
better than stand for larger data sets
or more complex models and that P may
have slightly steeper learning curve
that but can be worthwhile if we not
have to implant something very fast or
if you want to do something very complex
I would like to thank you especially
Thomas vley from P Labs he was very
important for me to do the best
Benchmark possible ensuring that this
Benchmark is valid and appropriate with
the current state of the library and I'm
open for question thank you very
much